i mean it's astonishing isn't it think
it's going to cost over 100 pounds for
most people to fill up their car how
high does the government expect fuel
prices to go well the situation is
difficult for many people um and of
course it's all consequence of uh the
war in ukraine and again we don't know
uh how the
the shock waves of that war will
continue to affect the energy market and
the price of petrol for people who are
hard-pressed and filling up their cars
but we have taken action to try to deal
with this situation the chancellor's
reduced fuel duty um and of course we
keep under review all the measures
necessary in order to help people with
the cost of living but that five pence
fueled duty and as much as has been
wiped out it was wiped out almost within
the week actually by by the increasing
prices
could the chancellor cut it further well
we always keep things under review but
one of the things we do want to make
sure is that that cut and fuel duty is
being passed on to the consumer so one
of the things that we do need to do is
to make sure that um on every four court
that uh every uh
outlet is making sure that it doesn't uh
take advantage of this situation to
build up excess profits advantage well i
think we do need to keep a a watch on
this and i know that the competition and
markets authority
and others will always keep an eagle eye
in order to ensure that we don't have a
situation where companies are taking
unfair advantage of consumers
supermarkets some putting up prices by
as much as five pence a day is there
nothing the government can do to stop us
well as i say it is important that we
look at the uh the behavior of
individual retailers supermarkets and
others and see what the pattern of
evidence leads us
uh to conclude um but i think it's also
important that we do all recognize that
the ultimate cause of the increase in uh
oil prices the increase in energy costs
overall is war in ukraine um it's a it's
a devastating conflict but we do need to
make sure that russia does not um profit
from its aggression but what about the
fuel companies themselves that should
they be taking lower profits do you
think are there any in particular that
you've got your eye on well uh again you
know the the uh the chancellor has been
clear um with the
energy level that he's introduced but
those companies that are making huge
windfall profits will pay their way into
helping people um with the cost of
living challenges that we all face at
the moment um nobody likes increasing
taxes but the chancellor is vigilant and
on the side of those people who are
struggling most at this time but but
what about the supermarkets what about
the the people delivering the fuel
could they not
should the profits that they are making
not be targeted as well well uh as i
mentioned earlier there are government
agencies that are in a position to
monitor what's happening um again i
don't want to single anyone out because
these are tough times for companies as
well as individuals but if it is the
case that we do have companies that are
behaving in a way which is
anti-competitive uh if we have companies
that are taking advantage of this crisis
in order to generate profits that are uh
excessive and unwarranted
because they're behaving in an
anti-competitive fashion then we can
take action okay
let's move on to the uh plans that are
we're expecting the prime minister now
today uh it's about right to buy isn't
it it's about helping people who are
housing benefit buy their homes this was
an idea of course that was pioneered by
margaret thatcher that she later said
she regretted
and has been derided by a lot of people
why is the prime minister announcing it
and why now i think the only people who
are deriding it to people who um in many
cases themselves own their own homes um
and don't want to see the the prize of
homeownership extended i think the the
criticism of it was that when these
social housing houses were passed over
into more people's ownership they
weren't replaced and so therefore there
wasn't the social housing to help those
coming up behind who needed it that is a
fair point and one of the things that we
will be doing is making sure that there
is a replacement i will like for like
one for one replacement how long would
that take though because of course we
all know that developers are sitting on
loads of land oh yeah it's hard to get
social housing built and a lot of social
housing is built as a one or two flats
and a big private development well we're
taking steps yesterday um i introduced
legislation to the house of commons that
means that there will be a new levy on
developers that means that when new
developments occur um when new homes are
built for sale by the big housing
companies we will extract some of the
money that they make but with planning
permission is granted the value of land
increases will take that money out and
some of that money will be set aside
explicitly to make sure that there is
more affordable housing more council
housing for people who need it but how
how can you say this is going to happen
within a set time frame i mean you know
if if a council sells 20 houses today to
tenants it's not going to they're not
going to have 20 new houses tomorrow for
the next lot of tenants it's going to
take years well the way in which the
levy works means that people can be
assured that when planning permission is
granted for new development that there
will be money uh in due course but it's
a long term councils councils can uh
borrow against that in order to invest
the truth with uh housing is that we
need more homes of all kinds we need
them in the right places we need them to
be high quality we need them to be
beautiful we need to be appropriate
infrastructure alongside that but one of
the ways in which we can do that um as
on legislation that we introduced
yesterday uh uh demonstrates is by
having a planning system that is
sensitive but also welcomes the right
development
in terms of the money though my
understanding and correct me if i'm
wrong is that
you can't get means tested benefits if
you have savings of 16 000 pounds
anybody who wants to buy a home and
unless they're getting 100 more which
needs some kind of deposit if you've got
15 000 pounds say 14 999 so you don't
you don't go over that cap
that that's a tiny deposit for for any
house there are no homes in the uk that
you can get for a hundred thousand
especially in london of course how how
on earth is it going to go to square
this financial circle there are
properties outside london than you can
but you are quite right um but one of
the challenges i mean there are two one
is um making sure that we have more new
homes the other one is making sure that
people have access to mortgage finance
and one of the things that we're looking
at is a way in which uh people can save
explicitly for home ownership um and
that those savings can be disregarded or
set aside for the purposes of uh people
receiving the benefits to which they are
entitled so we're looking specifically
at a savings vehicle that people can use
in order to make sure that they can save
for that deposit because homeownership
is not just good for individuals it's
good for society overall we want people
to have a stake in the future we want
people to be able to invest in their own
home we want people to have somewhere
safe and secure warm and decent in which
they can raise their children but if
people are on means-tested benefit
and just look at the fuel prices today
the cost of food as a result of the
ukraine crisis most people are all means
tested benefits are worried about
getting through to the end of the week
or to the end of the month they're not
going to be able to put aside money it's
it's it's a pipe dream for most people
that they can possibly save as much as
ten thousand pounds
well you are right that times are tough
at the moment and you're also right that
the number of people who uh can aspire
to homeownership has been reducing over
time that's why we're taking action um
and this action is intended to ensure
that once we we weather the uh
particular economic difficulties that we
face at the moment uh that we can ensure
that people are back on the path to home
ownership uh it's absolutely vital that
we uh reverse the decline in
homeownership that we've seen over
recent years isn't there also the issue
though that that if you do sell homes to
people at a reduced price because that
is that is also part of it that would
make it easier for people on low incomes
to buy them
the cost of replacing that that property
is more than the cost of selling it
there was a um a pilot scheme in the
midlands back in 2018.
authorities there said they'd replace
one form the average sale price was 137
000 um but the to build a new house to
replace that was 280 000. so
this costs an absolute fortune for the
government if you're going to be you
know spending a hundred thousand pounds
to replace each house that's a huge
amount of money where will that come
from is this new money uh it is it will
come from the overall parcel the overall
envelope of government spending at the
moment we expect that we will cap the
number of people who will be able to
benefit from this initially and then it
will grow over time but it's important
that government does invest in bricks
and mortar and one of the things one of
the things that my department does
already is to spend hundreds of millions
of pounds
in making sure that we can assemble the
land necessary to build more homes
particularly in urban areas because
there is a pressing need when we have so
many people on waiting lists so many
people in temporary accommodation to see
more homes built and that means more
social homes as well as more homes to
earn what will the cap be of people who
can do it uh well we're we're thinking
um
at the moment about exactly how many can
benefit each year and that's something
i'll be discussing with housing
associations because again of course we
have the resources to be able to to fund
a program of this kind but we want to
make sure that housing associations come
with us and they recognize that their
balance sheets are going to be robust in
the event of you must have offerings
if you're costing it uh we have costed
it but but again i don't want to get
into speculation about it
you know 100 people a thousand people uh
uh more than that but but but again one
of the things one of the things that i
know is that once you get involved in a
property auction uh like this you never
know where the numbers are going to be
so i won't get involved in speculating
at this stage
about the uh exact numbers because the
problem is when you don't talk about the
exact numbers it leads people to say
well hang on if we don't know exactly
how many people is this could be you
know half a dozen people it's a very
catchy policy which the government is
rolling out in a week which has been a
really tough week for the government and
and you know some would say oh
interesting timing that this has been
popped out this week uh well it's part
of a package of uh housing policy on
which we've been uh working for months
now and as well as the uh extending the
right to housing association tenants
it's also the case that we're
overhauling the planning system it's
also the case uh as i say that we have a
new infrastructure levy that ensures
that we can get more money from
developers it's also the case that
yesterday
we announced new powers for uh the
social housing regulator to make sure
that social homes are decent there is a
big range of policies uh that the
government is bringing forward in order
to make sure that people can own their
own home and that for those who are
renting that there is appropriate
protection as well so this has been in
the pipeline for some time and it is
part of the the suite of policies that
the government is bringing forward that
we're um are on your side at a time of
economic difficulty
let's move away from housing to the
situation uh with asylum seekers in
rwanda uh there was a plane due to take
a number of people out next week and
there have been a number of protests
about it it looks like the home
secretary's plan is going to face a
legal challenge
do you think this is a realistic
way of stopping this do you think that
this play next week will actually go yes
i do um and the home secretary was clear
uh she always anticipated we always
anticipated that there would be legal
challenges uh there are some uh
well-funded law firms uh that uh
understandably uh from their point of
view uh want to test this policy but we
believe that it is the right policy
we've secured
a cooperation agreement with rwanda
which means that
we will be in a position to
support that country and also support
them as they accept asylum seekers who
come here it's absolutely vital that we
take steps to break the business model
of people smugglers who are trading in
human misery what we want is a robust
but also fair policy on immigration so
you're not worried
uh no and i think it's also fair to say
that uh at the same time as we're
dealing with the uh the problem of uh
people smuggling um and illegality in
our migration system we're also showing
generosity the british people are
showing generosity uh towards people
from ukraine my department has been
responsible for working with the home
office and as a result we have more than
60 000 people who've come from ukraine
uh in the last few weeks and months to
the uk and i think that the british
people want to see
our borders
protected tough and robust laws enforced
but at the same time generosity extended
to those people who are in genuine
suffering generosity compassion
open-mindedness things all things that
we would like to be known for in the uk
and we've got a film about the daughter
of the prophet muhammad which has been
pulled from a number of uk cinemas we
spoke to sergey javid yesterday he said
he was very concerned about growing
cancer culture
do you agree with him over this i always
agree with the health secretary
on everything uh i can't think of
anything in which i disagree with
saturday but possibly sports a different
football team to me but apart from that
so you get on well with him um
what about the leader how did you vote
for him this week did you did you give
him your your support on monday
enthusiastically yes uh i think that
it's because you've not always been an
enthusiastic friend or supporter have
you no i i made a mistake in 2016. um uh
uh a misjudgment um if you've been in
politics for a little while as i have
been then um you know there are always
mistakes that you can look back on but
no i think the prime minister is doing a
good job and yeah i've been privileged
to work alongside him uh a when he made
sure that the the brexit entanglement
the imbroglio um was broken um i worked
alongside him particularly during the
clover crisis
he was
uh
very seriously ill recovered recovered
in order to lead
the world's most successful vaccination
program and a booster program that saw
us emerge from kovid ahead of other
economies and also um we've been
touching on the situation in in ukraine
um you don't need to take it from me
just uh listen to what uh vladimir
zelinsky said when he heard that the
prime minister had won the uh confidence
vote on monday he um an embattled war
leader expressed his uh delight that uh
that boris uh
in his own words you know one of the
strongest allies the ukrainian people
have uh had been vindicated in that vote
so you wouldn't run against him as a
potential new leader oh god no
what would you say to the uh 148 mps who
didn't agree with you have you been out
rallying for him yes i'm not i can
understand why uh
some of my
mp colleagues um uh have concerns um and
i think it's important that um over the
course of the the next two years that we
demonstrate that the government is
focused um on delivering for uh for
everyone across the united kingdom um so
you know one of the things i think we
need to to do is to uh move away from a
concentration on uh some of the you know
the westminster uh preoccupations
towards the people's priorities um and
in that sense you know what the prime
minister was saying today uh in
blackpool about extending home ownership
um and about helping more people onto
the property letter that is exactly i
know a concern that many of my
colleagues have um and i hope that uh
however they voted on monday when they
look at what the prime minister is
saying and what this government is doing
that it will feel reassured that we're
on track to deliver what we were
elected to deliver in 2019